spark is built something like this  at the very top we have spark core which  is the API that is abstracted out into  multiple languages like R SQL and python  among others to allow you to use the  code that you've already written and  plug directly into the Spark engine  second spark takes your code and runs it  on multiple nodes this is where Spark  starts to shine because sometimes the  data is too big for your machines or  it's way too expensive for you to  upgrade your machines spark handles that  using multiple nodes  and then finally  spark has a datastore solution itself  you can use something like Cassandra or  S3 to take all the data that you get  back from being run on your nodes and  store them onto the data store  and that's a little bit about Spark